j'adore le moonlight ses six salles
trois ambiances
parce qu'il ya en fait c'est souvent la
même ambiance mais ils ont dit y avait
six salles dans mes séries est ce que
vous aviez une boîte vous aviez tout le
temps où baptisée koala aux
milliardaires écoutez c'est dingue parce
que castel gallo mushkin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là le milliardaire ça m'agace indiqué
l'oms qui ne rentrait pas obliger
l'armée je connais très bien le
milliardaire mieux dernière alors moi je
rentrais chameau milliardaire a oui mais
un jour j'ai eu l'idée gvt est dragué la
fille qui s'occupait du carré dit garder
un nom valérie et il ya eu un petit bail
non et après je rentrais au mien mais
c'est bien connu et j'étais genre dans
le carré vip du mineur né à la cgt pas
du double ipa un jour les gens du doubs
qui suivait a brûlé la nuit et c'est
vrai je vous jure que c'est vrai au
milliardaire leumi dernière alors c'est
vraiment une boîte en fait il fallait
être milliardaire pourrait
donc c'est vrai qu'avec tout dégât le
gars qui rentre au milliardaire déjà
faire quand il prenait une bouteille
omis dernière tu savais que y'avait ton
loyer qui passe est grave
non mais c'était foutu payer son loyer
ou tu prenais une bouteille de
milliardaires voilà moi je préférais
payer le loyer donc voilà j'ai pas une
solution donc sans vous avez déjà pris
une bouteille d'eau mais derrière non
c'est parce que j'avais des amis qui
connaissent et toi une fois j'y vais
ouais je rentre dedans qui avait si
leonardo dicaprio ou non juré à bâiller
vu la mer l'a9 autour très joli nom et
maintenant je suis libéré et on se doute
bien ouais y avait non mais y avait
comme des filles comme ici
vous êtes magnifique là j'imagine daniel
moquet
[Rires]
c'est aussi leonardo
way maintenant oui comment ça parce que
j'ai un niveau d'avant dicaprio et
johnny est content
ces bons pâturages sipa conditions tu
vois si bien mais dans cette boîte à
lettres et surtout il n'osait vraiment
voici un truc que tu es un peu moche mal
fringuée tu dégages c'est très sympa
comme l'élection babeau c'est horrible
franchement d'auxerre et sécurité moche
mal fringuée moi c'était ce que j'étais
mais moi je suis dans la seringue est
alors entré jamais aux milliardaires
chinois jouent jeudi j'ai tout comme les
copines vous pourrez rentrer ou pas avec
les coptes avec des copines avec berthot
à l'égard des causes mais je me rappelle
très bien aux milliardaires il est
normal c'est un club privé
oui mais oui mais comment on fait pour
prendre la carte
de la car
après tout bien fait et on sait que pour
les habitués j'ai très envie d'être avec
donc en fait si vous laissez plus jamais
rentrée je serai jamais habitué donc et
c'est moi entrer puis après je connais
peu près tout
mais du fait que la jour vous savez ce
que c'était aux milliardaires c'est un
truc franchement je n'aurais jamais dire
quoi tellement que je ne rentrais pas je
suis arrivé un jour devant le
milliardaire
fait chier dessus et on arrête non
attendez entre edward et cher sinon non
je vous jure que c'est vrai et je suis
arrivé genre avec le zizi à l'air nom
pour voir si je rentrais mais je rêvais
très à l'aise aux beaux jours oui on est
deux
points devant l'alcool avait tellement
marre de ne pas rentrer jeudi battu à
braga alors si comme ça je rentre et des
musées pas but mais non non c'est que
pour les habitués et il n'est pas
habituel
[Rires]
sourire que c'est vrai et je n'ai pas
connu ni rien c est peut-être des
facettes des griots du coup nancy
vraiment que ça n'affecte la si longue à
un jeu très court j'y étais et j'ai vu
un de ses gardes du corps aj je sois tu
as parlé à l'un des deux camions et m'a
répondu lui ne souhaite pas vous parler
[Rires]
et depuis c'est fini c'est vrai que côté
le gamay non mais vous avez vraiment été
voir son garde du corps je souhaite vous
avez dit vous êtes qui m'a tout
simplement
n'était pas connu à l'époque non j'ai
pas ma carrière j'étais mal
deux semaines
c'est donc ya deux semaines
leonardo dicaprio d'abord et c'est non
c'était comme ça c'est en 2000 donc
c'était trois quatre ans après titanic
il était il était comme vous aujourd'hui
il planait était il avait le monde à ses
pieds c'est dessus en tout le monde
parlait et voilà et non je voulais jouer
elle voir le féliciter qu'on discute un
petit peu j'avais des projets à l'époque
de cinéma dont je voulais lui parler
eh oui si leonardo dicaprio nous regarde
là il va dire que derrière tout ça
là le gars
cgp l'arrêt franchement à l'aï acheté
oplev avec eux des meufs autour c'est
quand même impressionnant que les
petites meufs de 20 ans très jolie des
10 au 12 c'était quand même quelque
chose en règle c'est leonardo dicaprio
voyez la différence pour moi il honore
nos dicaprio
la différence elle est simple il ya le
loup de wall street et le loup de djerba
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand même deux salles deux
ambiances soir